I think it's a matter of probably a
matter of value valuing attention
valuing paying attention and valuing the
moment and realizing that the present is
the most elusive of all that the you
know you can stabilize the past because
there it is or you can at least
stabilize a set of memories and call it
the past you can stabilize the future
and that even though you don't know it
you can project a future and you can
dream about it or you can just think of
it as an object of curiosity but the
president is always disappearing and
there are ways to slow down this flood
of time through you know just a kind of
little meditation or just looking
stopping and looking I think that's the
thing I value and that's what I probably
am in that state you know a half percent
of the time but the poetry tries to get
into that a lot of it does anyway tries
to get into that state and arrest one of
those moments I have this kind of
crackpot analogy which is that you know
if this is old atomic through but if you
took it you take an atom and you smash
it you know matter is composed of atoms
and you smash one and it releases this
staggering amount of energy time is
composed not of atoms but of moments and
if you smash a moment there is also this
amazing release and the way to smash a
moment is not with a cyclotron but
through attention you smash a moment by
fixing it in your mind and and and I
think a lot of poetry haiku is a very
good example most little haiku poems are
just interested in isolating a moment
but that moment becomes a tiny thing and
suddenly it becomes every
at once it's kinda kind of recovering
catholic i went to a Jesuit I went to I
went to Catholic school from the first
grade right through college the full
metal jacket of Catholic education when
I got to graduate school is the first
time I've been in a classroom with a
female since the eighth grade so not
sure of the effect of that on me but I
don't have the i have i have all the
imagery of catholicism that's still very
vivid and vibrant and the faith is
something else it's very difficult in a
way to maintain a connection to a church
that is so full of flaws and an
hierarchically structured church Martin
Sheen I think summed it up best when he
said that he said I don't believe in God
but I believe that Mary was his mother
you know in other words you can you can
you can lose contact with the theology
but you can never lose contact with the
the iconography the imagery I think
these
I think you should see the people
courtesy is very much a part of it I
think I keep going back to Wordsworth
but he he he suggests that are the
better part of our lives the sort of
thread that connects our lives is is
composed of what he calls little
nameless unremembered acts of kindness
and of love and it's very important that
these acts are unremembered now if you
do something consciously for someone and
remember it well I mean an endowment is
a nice thing to do and get your name on
the gymnasium or the library that's one
kind of contribution but equally as
important I think to to stitch your days
together is just a kind of moving
through the world with the kind of
courtesy i think that leads to it seems
almost trivial in terms of that's like
like a point of etiquette but i think
courtesy leads to too much bigger things
but you have to start with the tiny
dress